this hairstyle is full of variety that's
right that's right that's fine the fun
never stops welcome to a stream of
consciousness vlog a stream of
lawlessness true of consciousness vlog
for those of you that don't know one I'm
grace Helbig let's start there
to do brush this vlog is a vlog in which
I just
quack about things that come into my
brain like ducks why they just looked
like cumbersome birds their whole life
looks like just it's difficult and not
rewarding and I get angry looking at
them so where's your God now usually we
don't start off that polarizing what's
happening it was Father's Day did you do
anything exciting other than Instagram
that one photo you have of you with your
dad
I've a Father's Day to all the internet
dads out there are gonna you Hannah Hart
I cut my finger yesterday I was washing
my dishes I had a glass space in the
sink and it started to topple over and I
reached for it and it cut me so if you
ever fall in front of me don't expect me
to reach out to help you I've learned my
lesson
I think sometimes you can learn a lot
about a person based on what they
surround themselves with so here are
some things that are around me right now
a light bulb from Ikea a cup wipes a
children's animal necklace making kit
from Target I'm actually super pumped on
this about this without any thought of
it actually being in a video and with
only thought of me making sweet animal
necklaces from my daily life jealous
look at Twitter see what's happening in
the universe right now that's such a fun
millennial way to figure out news check
Twitter to see what's happening in the
world
Oh Game of Thrones spoiler Khaleesi dies
yeah but she probably does someone back
oh this is my alarm to wake up humble
bag I woke up before my alarm because I
trouble sleeping based on my constant
paranoia of not getting work done the
dogs I asked about you watch basketball
if you miss the basketball game here's
what happened a group of millionaires
one and another group of millionaires
did not win here's a joke I thought of
the other day what do you call a happy
meal when a [ __ ] person is eating it
food for thought now all of you write
every other community and that's already
made that joke that I'm stealing from
what's the temperature gonna be like
today let's find out a high of 106
degrees the less popular boy band 106
degrees
send me 106 degrees you watched it here
first I put deodorant on so I bought a
yellow pleather jacket from Zara
recently the Internet's for sharing
video of a Labrador named Cody walking
in the hall what sounds like always
walking like I was walking like human
Cody are you seriously standing right
now yes he's seriously standing right
now oh my god oh my god he's evolving in
front of us he's holding a mirror up to
us oh my god Internet's for sharing
whose birthday is it today Nicole Kidman
is 49 years old today she's not a kid
man she sips
bf poses nearly naked oh that's fun Tom
Hiddleston the media has given you a new
name t-swift beer you're not a human you
are property
oh here's the top story on emus Kylie
Jenner flaunts booty in kris Jenner's
thong swimsuit thank God there are some
reliable news sources out there really
really documenting the important things
affect all of our lives who am I to
judge
look at this everyone's got to make that
shadow VidCon is coming up who's coming
to VidCon VidCon is super exciting I'll
put my schedule as far as I know it
right now in my description box below
we're doing a live version of not too
deep with glitter
I'm so so so excited to talk to Louise
on stage and I hope you guys come check
that out and Hannah and mamrie and I
have a big Q&A panel we have one every
year every year we try to bring a big
surprise to the panel and this year we
got big big surprise coming to this
panel also we'll be doing a live reading
a freak week at VidCon
there's an entire cast of amazing
characters that we've cast to read these
parts and it's going to happen Friday
night not just a reading there's like
it's a show it's like a full-on show
guys got any big fourth of July plans
only those of you that live in the
United States because just as I'm saying
this I realized that that's not a global
holiday so any of you guys have any
plans on the random date I don't know
July 4th or whatever
I think I should go because these animal
necklaces aren't gonna make themselves
and I have a very big important meeting
later today and I want to dress to
impress everyone I put that together or
not I hope you're doing this kind of
video I haven't done one of these in a
little bit if you did enjoy it please
give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe to this channel we're getting
closer and closer to three million
subscribers
and I'm going to do something really
really exciting for three million like I
actually do something I should think of
something to actually do incentivize
this of this hell big things will happen
how it just pinched where I cut myself
thanks for watching I don't know the
police are coming is it because of the
Kardashian comment or is it because you
didn't know the car - it was in a thong
and you gotta get over there that's an
emergency Amber Alert Kardashian and
thong thought so